hi i'm kendra hutchins manager of the
cornell annual trials program
i've run the program for five years now
and we've never had a year quite like
this one
cobit 19 wasn't even an issue when i
started sewing seed this spring
but then cornell closed down in march we
got permission to continue
our trials but it was a bare bones
operation co-workers pitched in to help
with transplanting
masked and socially distanced of course
with their help
we managed to get thousands of plants in
the ground 185 cultivars from eight
companies it was a hot dry season
but our new drip irrigation system
helped to keep everything looking good
sadly we had to cancel our field day but
we've continued evaluating cultivars
at the end of the season we'll post a
list of our top performers on our
website
where you can also find more information
about our program
until then follow our progress on
facebook and instagram
thanks for watching and stay safe this
has been a production
of cornell university